* Anschwellende Trommelmusik *
Die Ecole hoteliere de Lausanne
gehört
zu den renommiertesten Handelsschulen
für die Hotelindustrie.
2'800 Studenten aus über 110 Nationen
streben an der EHL nach Exzellenz,
Können und Selbstbewusstsein.
Wir begleiten drei Studenten
im Vorbereitungsjahr
und zwei am Ende ihres Studiums.
Alexandre Charlaix, 18 Jahre alt.
Mit seiner Matura in der Tasche
geht er in das Vorbereitungsjahr.
Emma Pittet ist 21. Sie wurde
in der Genferseeregion geboren
und beginnt ihr Studium
an dieser internationalen Schule.
Genau wie Alexandre Attia,
19 Jahre alt.
Der Sohn eines Hoteliers geht mit
Selbstvertrauen ins erste Semester.
Annina von Falkenstein.
Mit 21 beginnt sie
ihr vorletztes Studienjahr.
Die junge Baslerin strebt
nach nichts weniger als Exzellenz.
Afrim Beqa ist 27
und startet sein letztes Semester.
Der energetische Afrim möchte
selbstständiger Unternehmer werden.
Letztes Mal in "Die Hotelfachschule":
letzte Prüfung für Afrim,
sein Studenten-Business-Projekt.
Er beginnt mit seinem Team,
ein Firmenrestaurant für
die kantonale Versicherung zu planen.
Alexandre ist schlecht drauf und hat
auch nicht die richtige Einstellung.
Ich habe ein bisschen das Gefühl,
dass Ihnen der Respekt fehlt:
vor den Lehrpersonen,
aber auch gegenüber den Mitschülern.
Das ist frech und unprofessionell.
Und er musste
eine schwierige Entscheidung treffen.
Es ist sehr schwer für mich,
aber meine Zukunft ist an der EHL
und nicht beim Volleyball.
Emma leidet immer mehr
an ihrer Schulter.
Ich habe starke Schmerzen, das
fängt hier an und steigt nach oben.
Trotz der Schmerzen muss sie
während der von der Schule
organisierten Jobmesse
ein Praktikum
für ihr zweites Semester finden.
... si vous avez un CV?
- Oui, bien sur.
Alex entdeckt
die Freuden der Raumpflege.
Zimmerservice!
Die ekeln mich an.
Ich frage mich, was die machen.
Sauberkeit ist ihnen egal.
Achtung,
das muss Ihnen glasklar sein:
Was benutzen Sie für
die Toilette und was für den Rest?
Auf der Fahrt nach Basel
nutzt Annina die Zeit,
um für ihre Prüfungen zu lernen.
Sie ist glücklich, für ein Wochenende
das gemütliche Familiennest
zu geniessen.
Schon als kleines Mädchen,
mit acht, neun Jahren sagte sie,
sie wolle im Hotel arbeiten.
Los geht's. Mein letzter Schultag.
Die letzte Präsentation.
Ich spüre den Druck.
Es wird schon schiefgehen.
Hier werden wir
die Präsentation abhalten.
Der Saal ist leer.
Wir haben die Möglichkeit,
ihn zu dekorieren,
um ein gutes Bild abzugeben.
Wir holen nun die Dinge,
die wir benötigen,
um den Saal vorzubereiten.
Für Afrim und sein Team steht heute
die grosse Herausforderung an.
Sie vertreten ihr Projekt
für die kantonale Versicherung,
die sie mit einem Beratungsmandat
beauftragt hat,
im Rahmen ihrer Diplomarbeit,
des berühmten
Studenten-Business-Projekts.
Bei diesem entscheidenden Auftritt
zählt jedes Detail.
Natürlich der Inhalt,
aber auch die Kunst der Präsentation.
Um 7.45 Uhr werden Kunden kommen.
Wir werden sie begrüssen
und mit ihnen einen Kaffee trinken.
Dann werden wir
unsere Präsentation abhalten.
Wir werden hier vorne stehen.
Wenn wir fertig sind,
verlassen wir den Saal.
Und später werden sie uns
zurückrufen,
um uns mitzuteilen,
ob wir bestanden haben.
Dann werden wir wissen, ob wir
die EHL abschliessen oder nicht.
Zur selben sehr frühen Stunde,
einige Stockwerke tiefer.
Alex ist im Koch-Workshop.
Mission des Tages:
Guacamole zubereiten,
mit Freude und guter Laune.
Es ist hart am Morgen.
Ich sage mir einfach, wir haben
nur noch drei Wochen Unterricht.
Wir hatten seit Anfang Jahr
keine Ferien. Das ist hart.
Attendez! Stop, stop, stop!
Das geht so nicht, die Tomaten
müssen dreimal so klein sein.
Okay, Chef.
Hast du dich heute Morgen
nicht rasiert?
Non.
- Hein?
Keine Gnade für Haare, die die
Angewohnheit haben, nachzuwachsen.
Der Student hat 15 Min. Zeit,
sich zu rasieren
und in die Küche zurückzukehren.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Der Tag erwacht,
und Afrim macht eine kleine Pause,
um seinen Stress abzubauen.
Wird dir der Campus fehlen?
Ja klar.
Ich bin schon seit vier Jahren hier,
das hat mich geprägt.
Es ist ja noch nicht fertig.
Es bleiben noch 2 Std.
Allez!
C'est trop? Je refais.
Fertig, nichts vergessen.
Afrim denkt sogar daran,
den Raum zu parfümieren.
(Frau) Mmh, das riecht gut.
Werden Kunden, Dozenten und Prüfer
den Geruch bemerken?
Möglich, aber sie werden sich v.a.
auf das Konzept
der Studentengruppe konzentrieren.
Alexandre wird eine Prüfung ablegen.
Er hat keinen Stress.
Nehmt euch Zeit, beruhigt euch!
Wenn ihr fertig seid, könnt ihr euch
auf sozialen Netzwerken tummeln,
aber vermeidet laute Fragen.
(Laut) Monsieur!
Denn die anderen arbeiten.
Keinen Lärm!
Die Studierenden haben 20 Min. Zeit,
um die Fragen zu beantworten.
Am Ende jedes Workshops
werden theoretische
Branchenkenntnisse geprüft,
anhand von Multiple-Choice-Fragebögen
auf einem Tablet.
Nach 5 Min. ist Alexandre fertig,
als Erster.
(Flüsternd) Es war ein Kinderspiel.
Die Fragen betrafen die Theorie,
das war überhaupt nicht schwierig.
Alles mit ein bisschen Logik
zu beantworten.
Für andere scheint es
nicht so einfach zu sein.
Konzentration
während der erlaubten 20 Min.
Alle ausloggen! Putzt euer Tablet
und schaltet es aus!
Legst du meines zurück?
- Warum denn?
Mach einfach, sei so lieb.
Man kann am
Schluss die Antworten sehen,
aber das mache ich nie. Ich warte
lieber auf das Endresultat.
Und, bestehst du?
- Ich hätte mehr lernen können.
Aber das wird schon.
Afrim und sein Team
kommen von ihrer Präsentation.
* Wispern *
Ich denke,
die Präsentation war spitze.
Es ist cool,
wir sind stolz auf uns.
Jetzt warten wir auf das Feedback,
um zu erfahren,
was sie
von unserer Präsentation halten.
Aber ich denke, es ist gut gelaufen.
Albtraum hinter den Kulissen?
Der Koch des Gourmet-Workshops
bewertet jeden Schüler.
Wie geht's?
- Super.
Wie war die Woche?
- Die Küche machte Spass.
Nicht an die Wand lehnen!
- Entschuldigung.
Wie schätzen Sie sich selbst ein?
Was war diese Woche positiv?
Ich fand die Rezepte interessant.
Ich habe vieles dazugelernt.
Etwas,
das sie nicht gut gemacht haben?
Vielleicht die Konzentration.
Ja, damit bin ich einverstanden.
Sie arbeiten gut,
das steht ausser Frage.
Das Problem: Sobald Sie
mit einer Arbeit fertig sind,
verhalten Sie sich
wie ein Kleinkind.
Ich mag, dass Sie es
untereinander gut haben,
manchmal gibt es ja auch Streit
in der Küche.
Ich habe gehört,
Sie haben zuvor noch nie gearbeitet?
Nein, noch nie.
Okay. Denn jetzt werden Sie
in ein Praktikum starten.
Dort wird es um einiges strenger.
Sie werden bezahlt,
daher muss immer alles perfekt sein.
Also gewöhnen Sie sich daran!
Vielen Dank für diese Woche.
Merci a vous aussi.
Soll ich jemanden rufen?
Ja, gerne. Bringen Sie mir Bruno!
On y va.
Die Beratung der Jury hinter
verschlossenen Türen ist beendet.
Die mit Spannung
erwartete Entscheidung fällt.
Die Mitglieder der Jury, bestehend
aus unseren Partnern und Klienten
und Ihrem Coach,
teilen Ihnen gerne mit,
dass Sie brillant
und mit Erfolg bestanden haben!
Wir wünschen Ihnen zukünftig
viel Glück in Ihrer Karriere.
Glückwünsche und Bravo!
* Applaus *
Jetzt wird gefeiert.
* Beschwingte Musik *
(Alle) Sante!
Meine Mutter gratuliert allen.
* Treibende elektronische Musik *
Annina ist fleissig.
Die Prüfungen laufen seit Dienstag.
Dieses Wochenende muss ich mich
auf nächste Woche vorbereiten.
Mich erwarten fünf Prüfungen in
vier Tagen. Das ist etwas stressig.
Lernt ihr oft zusammen?
Nein.
Gar nicht.
Normalerweise
arbeiten wir nicht so zusammen,
weil wir nicht wirklich
auf demselben Niveau sind.
Ich sage lieber nicht,
wer weiter ist.
Normalerweise
kann ich seine Fragen beantworten.
Ich lerne auswendig,
das gibt mir Sicherheit.
Er liest es ein- oder zweimal durch
und kombiniert in seinem Kopf.
Das ist einfacher für ihn.
Annina
strebt eine besondere Erwähnung an.
Exzellenz steht im Mittelpunkt.
Ich arbeite gerne für die Schule
und möchte als Studentin
gute Leistungen bringen.
Ich bin sehr ambitioniert
und setze mir hohe Ziele.
Deshalb hätte ich das gerne
auch in meinem Diplom vermerkt.
Und ihre Deutschschweizer Mitbewohner
ermutigen sie.
Ein echter Fanklub!
Was ist denn mit deiner Tür passiert?
Ich kam rein, war genervt und habe
dann ein bisschen Dampf abgelassen.
Wieso warst du so genervt?
Dummheiten.
Ich werde eine neue Tür
kaufen müssen. 400 Fr.
Ist ein Liebesleben undenkbar,
hier im Zweierzimmer?
Nein, nicht undenkbar,
man muss sich organisieren.
Ich habe meinem Zimmerkollegen
eine Nachricht geschickt.
Unter Männern versteht man sich.
Alexandre wechselt sein Hemd,
und das aus gutem Grund:
Er wird wegen seines Verhaltens
zu einem Disziplinarrat vorgeladen.
Ich glaube, ich habe es verkackt.
Hallo, ich bin zuständig für Studen-
tenbelange im akademischen Bereich.
Wir kennen uns ja schon.
Ich bin verantwortlich
für das Vorbereitungsjahr.
Sie wissen: Im Vorbereitungsjahr
bezieht sich die Hälfte der Noten
auf Sozialkompetenz, Verhalten
und Respekt gegenüber den Dozenten.
Leider sind Ihre Noten
in diesem Bereich sehr tief,
weil Ihr Verhalten überhaupt nicht
den Werten der Schule entspricht.
Wenn ich die Kommentare lese,
habe ich das Gefühl,
wir sind hier im Club Mediterranee
oder in einer Ferienkolonie.
Doch vor uns sind Sie ganz anders,
Mr. Sehr-Perfekt,
führen sich gut auf.
Dieses Doppelgesicht von Klassen-
clown und Gentleman muss aufhören.
Am Freitag erwartet Sie
eine wichtige Kochprüfung
mit 30 Punkten.
Wir erwarten
ein tadelloses Verhalten.
Ich habe gehört, dass Sie
beim Kochen in 3-4 Min. fertig sind
und dann relaxen.
Nutzen Sie die Zeit!
Auch wenn Sie 5 Min.
länger brauchen,
kann das einen Unterschied machen.
Beim Praktikum wird ein
solches Verhalten nicht toleriert
und schädigt den Ruf unserer Schule.
Merci beaucoup.
- Au revoir.
Bon weekend.
- Bon weekend.
Ich denke, es ist
wegen dem Volleyball und all dem.
Das Vorbereitungsjahr
ist auch ein wenig langweilig.
Wir sind in der Küche
von 7.30-20 Uhr,
und müssen jeden Tag
die gleichen Jobs machen.
Ich denke, alles wird gut.
Ich muss mich nur
ein wenig zusammenreissen
und das Ganze
ein wenig ernster nehmen.
* Leichtfüssige Klaviermusik,
Stimmengewirr *
Sie sind nicht rasiert.
- Aber ich ...
Nein, das ist kein Männerbart.
Entweder einen Bart wie diesen
oder keinen.
Muss ich mich jetzt rasieren?
- Ja, unbedingt. Bis gleich.
Adlerauge alias M. Laurent
wacht über den Look.
Der Dresscode gilt von 7-19.15 Uhr.
Während dieser Zeit
bin ich auf dem Campus
und überwache das Verhalten
und die Kleidung, die wir erwarten.
(Frau) Bonjour.
- Bonjour, Mademoiselle.
Sein Hemd hing aus seiner Hose,
grenzwertig.
Gibt das eine Gelbe Karte?
- Nein, nein, nein.
Bei mir gibt es selten Gelbe Karten.
Ich habe sie zwar immer dabei,
aber die sind eher
für schlechtes Verhalten
und schlechte Kommunikation.
Wenn sich ein Schüler
an der Bar schlecht benimmt,
und unangebrachtes Vokabular
benutzt,
dann gibt's
eine Gelbe oder Rote Karte,
aber die benutze ich sehr selten.
Sie haben die Prüfung beendet?
Ja, ich habe einiges verwechselt,
aber egal.
Achtung,
der Rock ist ein wenig kurz.
M. Laurent ist super.
Das ist wichtig.
Aber ich mache das immer diskret.
Ich könnte ja sagen:
"Verlassen Sie das Gebäude!"
Nein, ich will ja konstruktiv sein.
Ich habe immer mein Tablet dabei.
Das sind alle Details zum Dresscode,
mit Beispielen,
wie man sich anziehen soll.
Mit dieser Unterstützung
kann ich die Studierenden
an die professionelle Erscheinung
und den Dresscode erinnern.
Ein schönes Beispiel
für einen gepflegten Bart:
Genau so muss er sein!
Wenn Sie müde sind,
dann gehen Sie nach Hause.
Hier wird nicht geschlafen.
* Entspannte Lounge-Musik *
Es tut gut.
Ich kann Musik hören
und habe 1 Std. Zeit für mich.
Danach geht es mir besser.
Trotz ihrer schmerzenden Schulter
ist es Emma wichtig, in Form zu sein.
Es geht langsam besser.
Ich machte viel Physiotherapie,
Übungen für die Halsmuskeln.
So konnte ich
meine Schulter stabilisieren,
aber seither
habe ich zu wenig trainiert.
Ich habe früher viel getanzt -
modern, klassisch.
Ich bin geschwommen und
habe zwei Jahre Jiu-Jitsu gemacht.
Dabei habe ich mich
am Hals verletzt.
Seit der Verletzung
mache ich Fitness.
Hier achten alle
sehr auf ihr Äusseres.
Die Lehrer sagen uns, unser Aussehen
sei wie eine Visitenkarte.
Also macht man sich
immer Gedanken darüber.
Und wenn man fit ist, ist das
bestimmt ein weiterer Vorteil.
Ich mach gerne Sport,
habe aber keine Modelfigur.
Der Dresscode ist anspruchsvoll,
wenn man klein
und etwas rundlich ist.
Das ist eine weitere Motivation
für mich, Sport zu treiben.
* Leichtfüssige Lounge-Musik *
Für Alex
beginnen die letzten Workshop-Wochen.
Dieses Mal macht er sich ans Sushi.
Die Stundenpläne sind voll,
die Müdigkeit macht sich bemerkbar.
Man hat an dieser Schule
nicht viel Zeit für sich.
Man muss sich persönlich
sehr engagieren.
Man ist immer hier und dort
und man steht immer.
Das ist schon hart.
Du kommst aus dem Kurs
und hast dann nur wenig Freizeit.
Musst du abends viel lernen?
- Nein, eigentlich gar nicht.
Das ist ein Vorteil dieser Schule:
Alles ist Praxis.
Wir müssen nicht
irgendwelche Hausaufgaben machen
oder Lektüre erledigen.
Ausser der Theorie.
- Klar, Theorie büffeln.
Ich habe mich geschnitten, Chef.
Tief.
Zeig her!
Armer Alex: Die Krankenschwester
kümmert sich um einen ernsteren Fall.
Er muss seinen Schmerz
geduldig ertragen.
Arbeit im Morgengrauen
in der Bäckerei.
Alexandre und seine Kollegen
bereiten Brötchen, Croissants
und anderes Gebäck zu
für die gesamte Schule.
Nachdem er zur Ordnung gerufen wurde,
ist er heute unauffällig,
fleissig und fokussiert.
Es ist die Zielgerade
vor dem Praktikum.
Fast alle gehen weg.
Ich habe einen Kumpel,
der nach London geht,
der andere geht nach Paris.
Er bleibt. Die zwei gehen,
nach Bali oder Paris.
Ja, viele gehen.
Schaut, so macht man das.
Alexandre hat sich
erst in letzter Minute bemüht,
ein Praktikum zu finden.
Er hofft, es in einem Luxushotel
in Villars machen zu können,
das sein Vater führt.
Aber die Idee
könnte nicht akzeptiert werden,
da die Schulordnung das Praktikum
im eigenen Familienbetrieb verbietet.
Hast du einen Plan B?
- Nein.
Ich habe keinen Bock,
ein neues Praktikum zu suchen.
Das ist kompliziert.
Wir werden sehen.
Ein Problem, das Alexandre
später am Tag lösen möchte.
Ich muss zum Studiendekanat,
um mit dem Verantwortlichen
zu reden.
Vielen Dank.
Ist nicht sehr tief.
Nur desinfizieren,
ich muss weiterarbeiten.
Passiert so was oft?
- Ja.
In der Küche gibt es viele Unfälle,
viele Verbrennungen.
Warum?
Es ist heiss in der Küche.
Die Schüler arbeiten lange,
sie schauen auf die Professoren.
Irgendwann ist man
nicht mehr konzentriert.
Und wenn man bis spätabends
gefeiert oder gelernt hat
und müde ist, geht es schnell.
So, das war's.
Der Verband
sollte nicht nass werden.
Sonst kommen Sie wieder,
damit kein feuchtes, warmes Klima
für Infektionen entsteht.
Ist das gut für Sie? Schönen Tag.
- Bonne journee, au revoir.
Es ist nicht tief,
aber es hat ziemlich geblutet.
Passt mein Finger da rein?
Ja, das geht.
Die Arbeit geht weiter
mit weniger Geschicklichkeit.
* Schnelle,
leichtfüssige Klaviermusik: *
* Sie verspielt sich. *
Mittagspause für Alexandre,
der danach einen Termin hat,
um über sein Praktikum zu sprechen.
Ich möchte mein Praktikum
bei meinem Vater machen.
Ein bisschen verhandeln.
Ich werde sagen, dass ich
in der Ferien schon dort gearbeitet
und mich im Team wohlgefühlt habe.
Im Reglement steht,
dass dies nicht erlaubt ist.
Aber ich hoffe, es wird akzeptiert.
Folgen Sie mir!
Und?
Er hat gesagt,
dass es auf keinen Fall möglich sei.
Das Reglement
sei für alle das gleiche.
Jetzt muss ich halt
noch ein Praktikum finden.
Ein definitiver Entscheid?
Ich habe ihm
meine Argumente dargelegt,
aber es gibt
keine weitere Diskussion.
Ich habe ja noch einen ganzen Monat
Zeit, bis die Praktika beginnen.
Ich werde eines finden.
* Entspannte Lounge-Musik *
Afrim ist seinen Eltern Nazife
und Beqir sehr verbunden geblieben.
Sprecht ihr immer albanisch?
Ja, auch mit meinem Bruder.
Mit allen, die albanisch sprechen,
spreche ich albanisch.
So verstehen uns
die Schweizer nicht.
Dieses Bett
bekam ich mit 16, ein rundes Bett.
Ich wollte unbedingt blaue Wände,
ein völliger Blödsinn.
Das war ich mit zwei.
Mein Onkel hat das gemalt.
Seine Bilder
sind überall im Haus.
Wo ist er?
Er malt immer noch, im Kosovo.
Das ist auch von ihm,
das hiesige Schloss Lucens.
Malst du auch?
Nein.
Da war ich acht Jahre alt,
als ich das gemalt habe.
Pointilismus.
Er war gut,
aber ... ich weiss nicht.
Ils disent n'importe quoi.
War es schwierig für die Kosten
der Schule aufzukommen?
Ja, es war schon hart, aber ich hab
mit meiner Frau diskutiert.
Wenn die Motivation da ist,
dann ist alles gerechtfertigt.
Afrims Eltern kamen als politische
Flüchtlinge 1988 in die Schweiz.
Was ist das da oben?
Das war mein Freund.
Wir waren zusammen im Gefängnis.
Er wurde vor dem Krieg von der
serbischen Polizei umgebracht. 1989.
Woher kannten Sie ihn?
Wir waren zusammen im Gefängnis
wegen Demonstrationen.
Er hiess auch Afrim.
Deshalb nannte ich meinen Sohn
nach ihm, um ihn zu ehren.
Afrims Eltern studierten an der
Hochschule Medizin und Wirtschaft.
Hier haben sie von vorne angefangen.
Ich habe bei Coop gearbeitet.
Nach und nach haben sie ihr Studium
wieder aufgenommen,
neben der Arbeit ihren Abschluss
gemacht und ihre Kinder grossgezogen.
Ich war schon alt.
Ja, mit 35 war es schwierig, mit den
Jungen mitzuhalten, den 20-Jährigen.
Sie sollten über meine Eltern einen
Film machen statt über die EHL.
* Angespannte Lounge-Musik *
Nach Dienstende
geht Emma auf dem Zahnfleisch.
Einen Kaffee, bitte.
- Um wach zu bleiben?
Bist du fertig um 21 Uhr?
- Ja, 21 oder 21.30 Uhr.
Was machst du heute Abend?
Nach Hause gehen,
trainieren oder ausgehen.
Ich weiss es noch nicht.
Mal schauen, ob ich fit bin
und nicht zu stark
nach Fritteuse rieche.
Ce qui est les cas a l'instant.
Merci beaucoup.
- Hier dein Kaffee.
Parfait. Merci.
Was hast du heute noch vor?
- Weiss ich noch nicht.
Wir werden sehen.
Ich bin Freitag und Samstag
ausgegangen, ich schlief nur wenig.
Morgen beginne ich um 6.30 Uhr.
- Das ist früh.
Emma will ins Buzz,
in den beliebtesten Klub in Lausanne
für Studenten.
Warst du im Fitnessstudio?
Nein, ich bin schliesslich
duschen gegangen.
Ich konnte einfach nicht mehr.
Heute war ein anstrengender Tag.
Ich mache morgen Fitness,
wenn ich nicht zu müde bin.
Jeden Montag gibt es für die EHL
eine spezielle Party im Buzz,
also werden wir hingehen.
Ich war das ganze Jahr
nicht im Buzz.
Heute ist die zweitletzte Chance,
also werde ich heute
zum letzten Mal gehen.
Bei Alexandre wird Champagner
getrunken, und zwar richtig.
Sante, auf die Werte der EHL!
Heute Abend gehe ich aus.
Frische Luft, Tapetenwechsel, ein
bisschen rumblödeln in der Stadt.
Man ist immer im Zimmer,
auf dem Campus. Das wird langweilig.
Die Abende hier sind nix.
Man isst die ganze Woche hier.
Das Essen ist viel zu teuer
auf dem Campus. 30 Fr.
Du isst viel,
aber jemand, der normal isst ...
Ich nehme immer zwei Portionen.
Ich hole mir zwei Steaks,
das zählt wie ein Menü.
Mit Dessert und einem Getränk
kostet das 30-35 Fr.
Ich finde das übertrieben.
- Und das zweimal täglich.
Das Problem ist: Es gibt hier
in der Nähe keinen Laden.
Man muss in die Stadt nach Lausanne,
die ist 25 Min. entfernt.
Man braucht 1 Std.,
nur um Nudeln zu kaufen.
Wir dürfen im Zimmer
keine Toaster oder Mikrowelle haben.
Wir müssen zwingend hier essen.
Nach dem Vorbereitungsjahr werden
wir unsere eigene Wohnung haben.
Unser Leben wird sich ändern.
So, jetzt wir gehen etwas trinken.
Diejenigen,
die es sich leisten können,
fahren mit dem Taxi in die Stadt.
Emma und ihre Mitbewohnerin
nehmen den Bus.
* Fröhlicher Gesang *
* Wummernde Bässe *
Die seriöse Annina ist in Budapest.
Vor vier Tagen habe ich
meine letzten Prüfungen geschrieben.
Ich denke, es ist eher gut gelaufen.
Ich werde die Resultate
aber erst im Februar erhalten.
Dann kann ich sagen,
ob es wirklich gut gelaufen ist
oder ob das nur mein Gefühl ist.
Natürlich ist Annina
nicht zum Sightseeing in Ungarn.
Sie ist von der EHL als Hostess
für eine internationale Konferenz
über Hotelinvestitionen
ausgewählt worden.
Annina und ihre Freundin
haben das Glück,
im prestigeträchtigen Luxushotel
zu übernachten,
in dem die Konferenz
am nächsten Tag beginnt.
(Englisch) Willkommen im Kempinski,
unserer bescheidenen Bleibe.
Folgen Sie mir!
Das ist Annina. Und mein Glas Wein.
Willkommen zu Hause.
Auf Budapest!
Das ist das beste von Annina.
Das ist Chante mit Pizzanase,
auch sehr aufregend.
Das ist meins. 100 %.
Hör auf, keine Kissenschlacht!
Habt ihr zusätzliche Kissen bestellt?
Chante hat online recherchiert
und ein Kissen-Menü gefunden.
Sie will jetzt jeden Abend
alle Kissen testen.
Ein kleiner Snack und dann ins Bett,
denn ein langer Tag kündigt sich an.
* Elektronische Musik *
Es ist der grosse Tag für Afrim,
aber auch für seine Eltern
und seinen Bruder,
die zur Diplomübergabe
und Abschlussfeier kommen.
* Stimmengewirr *
Wir werden jetzt alle Reden anhören.
Es wird sicher emotional.
Alexandre ist heute für die Dauer
der Feierlichkeiten im Service.
Momentan sind wir an der Bar
bis 16.45 Uhr, also 1 1/2 Std.
Heute Abend werden wir bis 22 Uhr
an der Bar Champagner servieren.
* Jubel und Applaus *
* Elektronische Popmusik *
Endlich ist es so weit:
eure Diplomfeier.
Wir feiern heute euren Erfolg.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch an alle.
Wissen Sie, was zu tun ist?
Alles abräumen
und neue Tassen servieren.
Genau. Immer alles nachfüllen,
alles schön abräumen.
Wissen Sie,
wie die Kaffeemaschine funktioniert?
Nein.
- Ist genug Wasser drin?
Nein. Ich geh auffüllen.
Genau.
Sind da genug Tassen?
- Nein.
Genau. Jetzt sollte alles klar sein.
Macht nicht alle alles
zur selben Zeit. Wer macht was?
In 20 Min. seid ihr fertig.
Wasser ist im Backoffice.
Die Angestellten haben uns gesagt,
sein Spitzname sei Speedy Gonzales.
Er ist sehr schnell.
Nehmen Sie alles auf einmal:
die Gläser, die Tassen.
Es ist wichtig, dass Sie lernen,
selbstständig zu arbeiten
und die Initiative zu ergreifen,
um alles schön anzurichten.
Finden Sie, das sieht gut aus?
Ich finde, ja.
Sie und Ihre Arbeitskollegen
können zufrieden sein.
Bedanken Sie sich
bei Pauline und Marie.
Sie haben Ihnen geholfen.
Immer bedanken.
Annina wird aktiv. In Budapest.
Jetzt hat die Arbeit begonnen.
Das ist gut, denn wenn man arbeitet,
vergeht die Zeit schneller.
Hier habe ich die Namensschilder
für die Registrierung.
Sie sind alphabetisch geordnet.
So geht es am schnellsten.
Über das ganze Gesicht strahlend,
begrüsst sie die Teilnehmer,
Investoren und Mitglieder
der grossen Hotelketten.
Das Speed-Netzwerken
beginnt in 5 Min.,
links am Ende des Flurs.
Wir freuen uns, Sie dort zu sehen.
Danke.
Sieht aus wie ein Business-Gespräch.
Ich hab nicht unterbrochen.
- Ich schon.
Ich nicht.
- Du musst. Bist du sicher? - Ja.
Willst du?
- Nein, du! Geh schon!
Annina
überwindet ihre Schüchternheit
und wagt es,
die Diskussion zu unterbrechen.
... to see you all there.
- Yeah, we will be there.
An der EHL
sind alle damit beschäftigt,
das Bankett für die Absolventen
und ihre Familien vorzubereiten.
Alexandre ist konzentriert,
arbeitet effizient.
Er weiss, man behält ihn im Auge.
Im Saal steht der langersehnte Moment
bevor: die Diplomfeier.
Wir überreichen das Diplom
für den Bachelor der Wissenschaft
des internationalen
Gastgewerbemanagements.
Und das Diplom
der Fachhochschule Westschweiz
für Hotellerie
und Gastgewerbeberufe.
Ils me rejoignent sur scene
maintenant.
Unter dem bewundernden Blick seiner
Familie betritt Afrim die Bühne.
Afrim Beqa!
* Jubel und Applaus *
* Entspannte Lounge-Musik *
Glücklich und auch traurig,
Freunde zu verlassen.
Aber es ist natürlich auch cool.
Annina beendet ihren langen Tag.
... macroeconomic indicators ...
Ich bin sehr, sehr müde,
ich weiss nicht warum.
Aber es war sehr spannend.
Ich konnte in den Saal
und alles mitverfolgen,
das war sehr interessant für mich.
An der EHL kündigt sich ein
heisser Abend an, ein sehr heisser.
Ein Megafest der Verkleidung
erwartet die Absolventen.
Die Geladenen
kommen durch die Gärten.
Gab's damals schon Ticketschalter?
Afrims Leibwächter:
seine Kumpel aus dem Quartier,
in dem er aufgewachsen ist,
und die alle mit ihm die EHL
begonnen haben.
* Prunkvolle Barock-Musik *
* Flippige Popmusik *
Und währenddessen Zeit:
Gewusel in der Küche.
Die Party wird vollständig
von den Studenten organisiert.
Highlight des Abends:
die Preise, die sich die Absolventen
selbst verleihen.
Zuerst das hübscheste Paar.
* Jubel und Applaus *
Leute, ihr seid alle
an unsere Hochzeit eingeladen.
Next one, please, Anton.
- Biggest AP hunter.
Dann derjenige,
der die meisten Mädchen
des Vorbereitungsjahres verführt hat.
Sein Name ist Afrim Beqa!
Ich weiss wirklich nicht,
wovon ihr redet, Leute. Ehrlich.
Aber, können wir einen richtigen,
der EHL würdigen Toast aussprechen?
Seid ihr bereit?
* Anschwellender Ruf *
(Alle) Sante!
* Eurovisions-Hymne *
Nächstes Mal
in "Die Hotelfachschule":
Wir empfehlen Ihnen, schon jetzt
ein Dessert zu bestellen.
Ein Souffle.
- Das geht. Ein Souffle, in Ordnung.
Man sagt nicht: "Das geht."
- Man braucht Selbstvertrauen.
(Frau) Herzlichen Glückwunsch
an die Gruppe!
Hab dich lieb!
Wir präsentieren das in Zürich
und nicht an der Schule.
Der Rahmen ist ungewohnt,
darum sind wir nervös.
Ich hab es
nicht absichtlich gemacht, Chef.
Wir reisen nach Thailand -
all inclusive,
ein fantastisches Angebot.
Das gibt's nicht im Reisebüro.
Ich hoffe, das Schwimmbecken
hat 28 °C, sonst gibt's Ärger.